What Hillsdale brings to Washington is a
deep understanding of principles that
principled statesmanship. I think that's
where the Kirby Center is going to be
focused, that's the people we are going to
develop and teach. We want to encourage
statesmen to be more ambitious and to
understand what, for example, are the
achievements of Washington and Lincoln
and Churchill to name three extremely
effective wielders of power who were
deeply devoted constitutional forms. It's
important to teach about the
Constitution in the nation's capital for
a very simple reason- it's supposed to be
the way they work things. Then the people
who are actually running the government
will be reminded that there is this
document, it's written down, it's not that hard
to read, it wasn't intended to be hard to read.
We are here in Washington D.C. to extend
the College's mission. We teach members of
Congress on a regular basis. We talk to
them, we spend time with them, we help
them write. We teach our students who
come from Hillsdale College. We teach
congressional staff that come to our various
programs, the public that come to our
lectures. The Kirby Center and having it
right there on Capitol Hill for my own
self has helped me get my thinking
centered in the right place, so that I'm not
just talking about policies or not just
talking about politics, but thinking
about First Principles and how they have
to be reapplied to the problems of the
day so that we can resuscitate the
American idea. It's our first remote campus,
but its roots have to be in the mission
of the college because we don't do
anything that's not rooted it there,
and we thought of this as a way to teach
the constitutional forms and principles
among the people who work under the
Constitution, and who also mostly have
forgotten what it means. If you can imagine
the early republic and people sitting
around talking about how to make it work, they didn't have any idea, any precedent.
The Kirby Center is reintroducing
that. So for the Hillsdale idea and
ideals to connect with Washington
political elites, proximity is key.
Proximity is what the Kirby Center
provides Hillsdale College.
Hillsdale is a community of scholars who,
in a collegial atmosphere, want to work
together to pursue truth, beauty, and
goodness. I think it's not only educational
in the think-tank sense, but it's also a
place that develops people and develops
students and grows theminto people who can use a
very lofty education for practical purposes.
There is that exciting element of young
people who are growing into adults who
want to do things with their lives. I
think that is the real spark of the place.
Architectures the ruling art. And the ruling art
means directing things toward its
purpose. We make our buildings and then
they make us. It's a very profound thing.
Think about that. You can say exactly
the same thing about a constitution.
First we make it, then it makes us. We
wanted to respect the principles of form
and beauty that go along with the
building of America. It's a really
beautiful building. So, aesthetically it's
great. It really reminds me of Hillsdale.
We always talk about the importance of
beautiful architecture and they really
took that here. It sets the stage for
continuing that serious education.
The classes and the internship were both quite demanding,
and learning how to be a good student, keep up with
my responsibilities here, but also do a
good job at my internship, and manage
networking and meeting with folks
afterwards. Sort of being able to do all that
at the same time and spin all those
plates was really valuable. Kirby Center
and Hillsdale College is helping guide us
back to that journey to we are what we
stand for and what made this country so
exceptional in the first place.
The people who who made the Kirby Center
happen-Mr. Kirby especially, but everyone
else who contributed to this place they
have done something that I think has changed
the conversation in Washington D.C. and
will continue to do so and will do so
more and more over time because of that
investment. Mr. Kirby is the leader of many, many
people who've given money so we can do
this. I would say to them
thank you most warmly. So far we have
done just what we hoped and we hope to
do yet more. And we're very grateful to you.